حزب الله يقول استهدفنا قاعده خربه ماعر
بالصواريخ واصبها بشكل مباشر اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي انطونيو تياني ان بلاده
ستوقف مساهمتها في تمويل وكاله الامم
المتحده لغوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
الاونر كما قال وزير التنميه الدوليه
الكندي احمد حسين انه يشعر بقلق بالغ ااء
مزاعم تورط بعض موظفي الاونروا في هجمات
السابع من اكتوبر واضاف انه اصدر تعليمات
بايقاف كافه التمويل الاضافي للاونروا في
انتظار نتيجه التحقيق وفي الوقت نفسه عبر
الوزير الكندي عن قلق بلاده البالغ اذاء
الازمه الانسانيه في غزه مشيرا الى انها
ستواصل العمل مع الشركاء في المنطقه
لتقديم الدعم الانساني وفي استراليا قالت
وزيره الخارجيه فييني وونج ان استراليا
ستنضم الى الولايات المتحده وكندا في وقف
تمويل الاونر ومؤ م ق مشيره الى ان
استراليا تشعر بقلق عميق ازاء هذه المزاعم
وفق تعبيرها
ورحبت وونج برد الاونر الفوري بما في ذلك
انهاء العقود وبدء التحقيق وكذلك باعلانها
الاخير عن اجراء تحقيق كامل في الادعاءات
الموجهه
للوكاله وفي السياق نفسه ضمن هذا الخبر
العاجل وزير الخارجيه النرويجي يقول
للجزيره الوضع بالنسبه لسكان غزه كارثي
والاون اهم منظمه انسانيه في القطاع دانت
حركه حماس بشده ما سمته تحريض الكيان
الصهيوني على المؤسسات الامميه التي تساهم
في اغاثه الشعب الفلسطيني بينها منظمه
الصحه العالميه والاونو واضافت الحركه ان
التحريض يهدف الى قطع التمويل وحرمان
المدنيين من تلقي حقهم في الخدمات التي
تقدمها تلك المنظمات الدوليه
ودعت الامم المتحده والمؤسسات الدوليه الى
عدم الرضوخ لتهديدات وابتزاز الاحتلال وفق
تعبيرها واكدت حماس على اهميه دور هذه
المنظمات في اغاثه الفلسطينيين وتوثيق
جرائم
الاحتلال رحب وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
يسرائيل كاتس بقرار الولايات المتحده
وكندا وقف تمويل الاونروا وقال ان على
الاونور ان تدفع ثمن افعالها وفقه عبيره
كما اضاف كاتس ان عددا من موظفي الاونور
اعضاء في حركه حماس وفق ما قال ويتعاطفون
مع ارائها ويساعدون في توفير الماوى لانشط
تها والحفاظ على حكمها واشار الى انه
سيضمن الا تكون الاونور جزءا من اليوم
التالي للحرب في غزه وان تحل محلها جهه
اخرى